OK. So yeah, we're doing minimum
and maximum and min Max.
Yeah, it's the normal
loop of just comparisons.
For Min Max you get.
Ah, you get a different
Max element than for Max.
Right, if there are multiple.
In the array so. I feel like,
oh we have algorithm which GitHub
doesn't recognize. Let's see.
Plus plus I don't know why that is.
I thought we fixed that.
Can I recommend zooming in
so that it will be visible?
Alright, and in that case we should
probably go back to the unified. View.
Umm? Yeah, alright, so this is for.
Results and then one function for
each size for one by two bytes,
4 bytes and eight bytes. Umm?
And I can use the vector out.
The vectorized algorithm for
like 3 bytes or five bytes.
On alright, so here's the actual.
Uhm? Templated at three point that
picks which one it used to call.
There's a bunch of reinterpret casts here.
Yeah, so this file is strict
aliasing I think. But the.
The code it's calling here.
Steadman element uh once it is done with.
Yeah the code is calling in here.
Uhm, it's always gonna be compiled
into our uh import library.
Or or vector algorithms goes?
So it's always compiled with MSVC,
so we don't really.
Violate strict aliasing, it's OK.
Am. And. We don't have a huge
amount of choice, honestly.
So.
And then it's the same thing for
my Excel and we just and this
one's easier to see because you
don't have the big comment. Umm?
So if we're a pointer or a null pointer,
then we do all the reinterpret
casting thing we.
We were crazily called ourselves after with.
You had pointer which is gonna
go to this branch of the L. Umm?
Let me just branch on the
sides. Same here. Ohm.
Here were deciding whether. To turn stuff on.
So that's going to be. Work day US. UM?
We're not iterating over volatile.
I I iterator is volatile.
I believe it's an iterator
over volatile stuff,
not a volatile iterator itself,
right? That's right.
Yeah, yeah, because then
you would use is volatile.
Badly needed.
Or were integral or pointer and. Uhm?
Let's see, yeah, our predicate
is less or vangelos.
And that.
Here we could have used our
internal is any of the.
Nowhere on 9188. I don't know.
I don't think that would
probably buy any clarity.
UM, it is something that
we used elsewhere.
Yeah, I don't think it
would increase clarity.
I think the clarity here comes from the
very nice comments that explain each step,
so it's not just right.
Here's a bunch of in line.
Yeah, well, because that could that
that would only do these interval or
is pointer which is kind of obvious
because it all gets on one line.
Yeah, if this was over multiple lines.
Umm? Or or or had like a conjunct
like had other stuff in here then
maybe what's on is any of you wouldn't
replace the one about his interval
that one has to be a disjunction,
it it could replace the one that's
the disjunction is same is any
of the he says is P no,
but that would be awful because we we have.
We still have the preprocessor
thing right in the middle.
Yes yeah, for the range of what's the point?
Yeah, it'll look pretty ugly.
It would avoid repeating
his name three times, but.
Didn't buy anything.
It's NPR, really,
but yeah.
I'll point it out,
but not request a change that
seems reasonable, just sort of.
Just record the rationale.
I think we do use preprocessor
conditional with. Is any of the.
When we're looking for things like
characters types that could be bite
because we have them stay catch for bite.
So we brought in the same sort of scenario,
but it's again.
It's the preprocessor damages clarity.
Something that really should be standardized,
like somebody should just propose
this is any of the for this because
it's a useful thing with like this
specialization fee like is implementers,
we keep all the cool stuff for ourselves.
I think it's just us in, UM. Write it down.
And also. Well, that's an ex utility, right?
That's a good point. Yeah,
is any of you is defined pretty high up.
I can't remember if it's
utility or type traits.
It's definitely available.
An algorithm algorithm has everything, yeah?
UM? Yeah, I think it's probably
a an instance of like these type
traits being so small that like.
It's a lot of effort to like do
the whole paper and everything.
Yeah and everything and then.
You know it kind of just
comes up on occasion.
Nobody's kind of gone through
to collect all of them.
Yeah, this so somebody would
have to go through the various
standard libraries and kind of.
Uh. Patch them altogether I think.
Yeah, like we've all reinvented,
always false. That's a very popular one.
That one is getting standardized, it is.
Or finally, I thought it was wow.
It's our time. Well, I had to write one.
I had to reimplement that in a in AMP.
Which I mean, I guess I could
have used the one from the STL,
but I don't wanna use SCL internal
stuff in app even though AMD
thinks it's part of the SDL yeah?
Umm? Yeah, let's see.
So this was me being an idiot.
So don't worry about that.
Yeah, this is a if constexpr thing,
so it's. Yeah. Uhm?
An element.
We call min element.
Min Max. Comment Max on that and
then construct. You know maximum
or minimum maximum element.
See so before our pointer we return
them directly. Ohh, if the if
the iterator is a pointer. Uhm?
Is this right or do we have to like do fits
unfancy and I believe this is correct.
It's basically if the iterator that
the user came to us. Actually.
This is interesting because the context
is it's the unchecked algorithm,
so we've already potentially
unwrapped the iterator.
OK, like vector iterator,
we have metaprogramming that
unwrap that down to a raw pointer.
Seems like string iterators then this,
then goes and calls minmax element.
So if after unwrapping we had a pointer,
then whatever minmax.
On that returned it returns.
Point is, we can just return directly,
so that's line 9412.
But if even after unwrapping the
iterator is not a pointer like it's.
A deck iterator or list iterator or
something by directional unwrapping's
not gonna give you a pointer.
So if it happens to be actually
sorry in this case,
if we were eligible for the optimization,
we would need to be at least contiguous.
So if you had a contiguous iterator that yet
did not unwrap all the way to a pointer,
or if it's a user iterator, right?
Yeah, a user defined iterator that.
Unwrapping doesn't make into a pointer.
We need to at this point restore the original
iterator type, and that's what we're doing,
so it's like 2 levels of unwrapping,
which is a little weird.
But this is the correct pattern that,
well, no, it's not.
That's not what this is doing,
it just constructing the.
Return value which is 2 iterators but yes,
but it's 9414.
That would restore the iterator type, so.
Yeah, yeah, I can use that right?
Yeah yeah, sorry no.
I think we understand understand each other.
Yeah it's yeah it it.
It has to actually return the
right types so or no, no.
Actually it's doing the opposite of that.
It's the result is to void pointers.
Umm?
So if it's not a pointer.
We're taking.
Oh no, it's returning a pair of four letters.
So it's it's really.
Yeah, it's user defined
iterators that are contiguous,
so we can get pointers that would.
Be eligible for the vectorized algorithm?
Yeah, but they don't.
The Unchecking machine for iterator
debugging doesn't actually wrap
them all the way to if we wanted to.
Yeah, yeah.
Which is probably indicates we may not have
test coverage for that interesting scenario.
I think we do, so it's like.
This is a wrapper for is.
This is presently moving and moving is
constant evaluated around somewhere.
I'm pretty shocked that
this didn't already exist.
Yeah, we were very consistently
guarding it with CX-20.
Yeah. So that's a kind of policy thing.
I guess this would be the first
PR that uses that that level.
Though. Yeah.
I'm not entirely sure why we can't just
use the built in directly, but. Umm?
Are you gonna break courtesy?
I mean yeah, like that that's
already guarded by could.
In fact I'm I was wondering why we
have to specifically test for crews?
C beer. I thought it was
already part of Houston.
Vector algorithms.
I can't remember why I I think it's
that we're usually pretty scared of
using built INS just here and there
scattered about the source code.
This originally came up with the
Titrates like double under score
is enum is class those they work
perfectly fine when they're used in
the context of I'm gonna be given to
like roll constant within type traits,
but if we started just using them scattered
here and there throughout the STL,
those built INS appearing at
different strange places in this.
That's the compiler was not always
prepared to handle it cuz the builtins
are like they're sort of these sort of
custom things that the compiler handles.
They're not really full fledged
like keywords, and you know,
really tanked into the compiler,
so there have been compiler bugs
in the past caused by using built
INS and unexpected.
That explains quite a lot about
our approach to a lot of yeah.
So just to avoid bugs,
we have traditionally sort of
centralized our usage of builtins and
intrinsics into helper functions.
So we're gonna say, here's the one function.
Why there has to get right and
then we can call this function
elsewhere and then it's an ordinary
function call and everything's fine.
So we continue doing that even
though compilers these days,
like MSVC is way more robust than
it used to be due to the massive
improvements from the front end team.
But we're still, you know,
for consistency, like to do this and it
still helps occasionally point bugs,
so it seems reasonable I'm fine doing that.
It's a little scary that this
whole thing is guarded by Kudo CC,
but if we screw it up, you know.
You'll notice it immediately, so.
And then we get to the meat of the thing.
So this is.
The same,
it's just so we don't have to
include algorithm again.
One could argue that this could be a simple.
Pair we could just destructure it.
Up there, but actually no.
This has to work in in 14 mode.
But yeah, I don't have a problem with this.
This isn't gonna change.
It's not no DVR violation or any.
UM? So. Now we have templated.
So this is just the normal algorithm. UM?
Let's see. Yeah, and current just
comes in through a parameter,
and yeah, this is literally just the.
Minimum maximum. And then Min Max
which is different right we? Umm?
Yeah. Use less than or equal here. Uh.
Yeah, and it's now statement.
Because the mayor of maximal
ones can be the same. Uhm?
OK. And then there's enough.
Which will come up later.
Explicitly 1-2 and three it's.
It's a, it's a.
It's their flags. Umm?
Well, that's interesting.
Should we have a comment?
Yeah, maybe I?
I that's actually I that that was
my suggestion to make them flag.
I didn't put a comment when I suggested it,
but yeah, either that we'll come
back to that and I'll suggest it
again to do it either with a comment,
or we could just do put the shifts in.
To make it clear, yeah,
I either shifts or or comment.
I would be fine with either and and if
there were more numerators like if it was,
you know 1248 sixteen,
then the pattern would be obvious, but
123 it looks like an arithmetic progression.
Yeah, right?
Even if we're never gonna
extend it with like, you know,
Ultraman and Ultramax in the future,
and yeah, anyway. Uhm, yeah.
So then.
Uh,
this is,
let's see.
And this handles all of them
and ties them together.
So this is if we're only doing min. Uhm?
We'll get to the same thing later.
This is we're only doing Max and
this is implicitly both the reason
that they're flags will be. More.
The reason why fly isn't improved
clarity will come up later, right?
So these are traits,
so these are to pull out the size specific.
Uh, doodad vector doodads.
So. Has portion Max means.
Like
Umm?
It the is the maximum number of. Uh.
Of chunks that we can
process before we have to.
Like actually pull out
the real minimum element.
We'll get into that later.
Umm? And then you know the.
Minimum and and and and maximum.
Values. Ohm. This flips the sign. Of. Val
if you specify size so. Uhm?
If sign is false. Then it. Ah.
Then it flips the sign,
otherwise it does not. So if there are.
Yeah, what does core mean here?
Corrections ohh OK yeah so this is.
This is the top bit. OK, yeah,
I understand what the function is doing.
Sort of attempting to avoid duplicating
all this code for signed and unsigned
times 1248 bytes, which is yeah,
exactly definitely worth a little
bit of centralization here.
I was just confused because
like core is like.
And seen that abbreviation before I I I?
I mean I, I think it's corrections.
Alright, increment that's obvious,
so age funk. We'll get back to this.
Uh. Later, so I yeah,
so that's the trade we'll come back to it.
Should should we just ask
for a comment on that?
At least the first occurrence of that?
Because if it's if it's an abbreviation
we've never seen before in the STL,
it feels like it deserves a comment.
Yeah, for stuff like you know,
shuff and.
English that those are self explanatory.
Uh.
Right, uh, yeah so that's that
we'll give back to all that stuff.
It's pretty cool that we can use the
vector instruction like flip the signs
of like what was that 16 or whatever
elements all at once. That is the.
Yeah. UM?
OK, so this is the actual algorithm. UM?
Yeah, let's see. Uhm?
We initialize stuff.
Pieces first Min Valley is
the smallest possible value.
Max value is the biggest possible value.
Umm? If we have more than.
16 bytes uhm in our rain.
And SSE 4/2 is on. And.
The the size of the vertical.
The vertical, min and Max portion.
Ah. Is this bug aligned?
UM?
Like, uh, align?
Doesn't multiple of 16 OK?
Well, what do you mean by
vertical minute Max portion?
We'll get there.
So OK, I guess what I'm kind
of looking for is like, yeah,
let's do the let's do the overview
of the algorithm now,
which starts. Uh.
Yeah yeah here yeah OK yeah OK so.
Do you need to switch the
camera over? No, yeah, thanks.
Let's actually get into it now.
UM?
So.
If we have, let's do this in reverse
order, so let's say, let's see.
Save Ohh actually right sorry.
So let's say we have.
And let's consider 32 bit.
Perfect, yeah, so let's consider
third the 32 bit elements.
On so. What we're gonna do is.
So we're splitting it up.
Like that, and then we're
gonna compute the elementwise
minimum of all of those.
And in the code this is called the.
And vertical minimum presumably.
UM? Yeah, the vertical.
Presumably because.
The idea is that you're
kind of forming like.
Look, you get. UM?
You know one. 5. 9.
And then. Ah. To.
Well.
Laying stuff out like this
and then each time you go
through you get the minimum of.
Of the of the of this vertical column.
Right, OK, so you end up.
Finding the minimum one that
occurred at position 0 Mod 4142,
Mod 4, and so forth so.
So we keep the state
when we're going through.
We keep 2 vectors.
Keep the valley,
the value and the idea X.
So yeah, so like.
The first time through.
Let's see, you would find.
Question for those watching,
can you see what's on the whiteboard?
Just checking so that we've got, UM,
the right do we might wanna turn off auto.
Camera settings so that when I
walk in front of it, it doesn't.
It doesn't like right now.
Yes, I can read what's going
on on the white board.
I think you guys need to stop
sharing though for the video to work.
OK, let's do that because right
now it's like I have, you know,
just Charlies video maximized and
we need that on the video instead
of your window with the tiny little
video showing up in the corner, OK?
And I think, Oh no,
it's it's that's turned off.
You may just want to write larger
and use maybe the green one because
I was looking at like the Dal
and that's like very very.
I can barely see it in person.
Yeah, might be running.
Yeah, that I couldn't see at all.
I didn't know there was something
there until you pointed it out.
But the red shows up.
I think I think that one is cursed and try.
Yeah, that was good. OK so yeah so we keep.
Now and so it would be, you know. On
ohh man, I wrote everything
backwards in that matrix because I.
Which is gonna make things
harder because you get a.
The easy thing is it's. Yeah.
Like you start, you know you can
start with 1211, ten, nine and then
we do the comparison. Against. Uhm?
Alright and so.
Each. Each element, and by the
time we're done. We get. Aye.
By the time we're done so so. We get.
From here we get the element wise minimum.
And then by the time we're done,
we get the minimum of each column. Right so.
Alright can I can I check my
understanding that that that's
why it's called the vertical.
OK, so if our input instead was 12?
Negative. 99 uh, ten and nine,
then 8. Seven just do 265.
Just do two, yeah.
Where you like it?
I guess negative makes it more confusing.
No, that's fine, OK, but just two chunks.
OK, like this, yeah?
Yeah, then we would compare element
wise so then you get 12 to ten
98765. So comparing these two
parts and probably standing
in front of the camera,
if you're getting the minimum.
This one wins.
This one wins this one,
this one, and so we get
8265 for each possible location Mod 4,
and at the very end after the whole vector
thing has given us a sort of vector of the
smallest ones found at each position mod 4.
Then we can do just a few
instructions and fight.
Oh wait, two is the smallest of all evolved?
Yes, that's that's exactly what happens.
And actually we could implement this for our.
For the scalar algorithms,
it would probably be faster
than what we do now.
Interesting because it.
It means that the the the loop
dependencies are much further apart, alright?
Because we can if we're talking
between like 12 and 8:00 and 2:00
and 7:00 and 10:00 and 6:00,
we can do all those comparisons and
we don't need to care about the
results of them until much later.
We're currently greedily saying OK,
we need to.
Through 12 and two into comparison
and then whatever that comes out,
we compare that against 10.
That's a huge chain of dependencies.
It's sort of the difference
between a tree that looks like.
This versus a tree that looks like trade,
some zooms.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and and and so that that would be
potentially useful for like user
defined types or word sizes, but.
Yeah, it's you trade off.
You know the storage space and also
at the end you do MLN comparisons.
Yeah, which is just kind of.
Because vector.
Oops, not any algorithm reason anyway.
Anyhow, so while you're doing this,
you also keep track of the of
the indices of the minimum,
so.
In right because this is min element
and so forth and we need to know
where or not just would value.
Yeah,
we need to know where and and
that's also true at the end.
If we get duplicates, yeah, OK yeah
because they have interesting semantics.
I I had to learn this because I think we had.
We had like a bug report that we did
the wrong thing in min Max element.
Minmax element is not the same as just
doing mid element to do a Max element.
It's different to the different minimum.
Sorry it gives you the same minimum.
It gives you a different maximum
and the case of duplicates. Yeah,
just because of how the algorithm works,
it's inherent to the algorithm.
Well, I mean it's specified.
That way, yes, it's specified well.
Do it with a with a with a greater
than comparison, yeah, but yeah,
I think you really want to be for comparisons
or not follow the STLS prevention of use.
Yeah well so the the Max element is
a greater than or equals comparison?
Or is Max's? Uh, greater than so
I think min Max element the Max.
Actually. That was more comparisons.
Yeah, I don't need to look at it again.
I remember to achieve its
three in over 2 comparisons.
It naturally output a different value
in the case of the tie breaker.
Ohh God, does that mean this doesn't conform?
This one may be fine because it's integers.
Ooh, that's a good question about location
no, but the N log N comparison thing
doesn't matter because it's it's not.
It's it's north log N for just the the
vector size chunk, so N is constant.
OK, yeah yeah that's fine then yeah, we can.
Definitely constant factors.
I was more thinking about what locations
do we return in the case of equivalent
answers and even though we're integers,
which actually doesn't matter,
we do it right. Yeah, OK, good,
as long as it does so once we're done once,
we're at this step.
We need to find Oh yeah, right.
So portion Max.
Right, so we keep the indices,
so for a moment because it's a little easier.
Let's imagine we have a really tiny.
One bite. Uh, really tiny vectors.
A 32 bit vector, right?
So 48 bit values.
OK, right?
So we keep the indices and eventually.
We get to the 255th comparison
and we need to wrap around,
so that's what portion size is where,
if you like.
That probably wouldn't be your vector,
but it could be right if all of your
minimum elements were at the very end,
like if you get here, you have to stop
doing this and you have to rectify.
You know you have to do the second part.
To pull out the real minimum
element here or store it.
And then reset this stuff and continue again.
OK, I think I think you lost me.
So you're you're storing a
vector of locations, yes,
so there's the index vector.
OK, but you're only using a byte
for the locations. Is that right?
Yeah, this is just so that I don't
have to write out to the 32.
Oh, I see. So, OK,
so you're physically actually storing it.
This is exactly happens so.
Yes, because we use the same
size vector for this and this.
Ohh there for the for the locations
yeah OK so so so there actually is a
mismatch between size T on the platform
and the number of bits that we can
dedicate to storing indices right?
So that's why we have to worry about
running out well size T you know 64
bit vector you get two of those.
Right? OK, because these are one
2128 bit vector instructions.
Yeah, it's to see whatever and and and.
Also you can't.
You can't like shuffle between.
You you can't do the the clever
stuff that is done to keep the, uh,
the values and the indices and sync and
then to tie them together at the end.
If the vectors are different sizes, right?
Yeah yeah, the same size
will need to be the sad,
they're the same size and they can overflow.
OK, so this is the case of. If we have,
is it 4 values per vector or does it?
Does it varies.
It varies between, right?
Yeah, varies by elements.
So first if we got a lot of elements per
actual one byte elements, you get what?
16 indices and 16 values per chunk.
16 I think that's right.
Yeah, OK, so for one byte we get.
I'm trying to do the division of my
head was that 32 bytes per chunk.
64128 No, no. It's only 1616 bytes per chunk.
What 16 bytes per chunk,
no matter what, because it's OK,
it's 128 bit vectors.
OK, I actually yeah, I I would.
I would appreciate a table here.
So we've got like 1616 byte.
Actually they is there
an in an AVX 256 version.
You know VX two yeah.
So it's like we have.
16 Bites, I think there's.
And one. And.
And the size of teas, maybe the way the
camera has fallen since I put it. Ohh no.
You sat on the chair with the camera.
This is like yes Oh yeah no it doesn't.
Yes you can. It doesn't have
this one really great on YouTube.
This should be our thumbnail.
Video editing please.
If yeah, OK, yeah, just don't don't.
Bigger trouble just in case anybody out
there thinks that we're not software
engineers and that we're actually just,
you know, content creators.
We've proven it.
OK so I was wondering 16 bytes on size of
T could be one to four eight and so then.
Elems her portion.
Of the terminology or junk, yeah, I.
I think chunk no yeah chunk because
portion is or portions different.
Yeah OK portion is the number of chunks.
Ah which makes sense right?
You when you're eating you one
chunk of of food at a time and the
number of chunks is portion size.
OK, so you can have 16,
eight, four or two UM.
And if you are because this
works on both X86 and X64,
so for X86 we would need 4
bytes for pointer and then for
X64 we would need 8 bytes.
We're not storing pointers
right pointer size?
Keep saying same deal so here.
If we have 16 bytes in a chunk
and we have two elements,
then that is exactly OK for storing size T,
so we can just store no true size directly,
no, no,
you can't because each element
here is going to be 32 bytes,
each element is going to be 32 fights,
but I said what the size of T is 80.
Sorry, sorry yeah, you're right,
you're right. OK, so in this case.
The size of T always works,
and in this case we'll reach 4 elements.
Then we're camped at.
16 / 4 square. So we're
captive 2 to the 32 times that.
That's fine on X86,
but we do run into overflow on X64 here.
We're capped at 2 to the 16,
and here we're capped at 2 to the 8th,
so that's the 2:55 you were talking about.
Yeah, OK, so I see. So if as the.
Element size gets smaller.
We need to pack more indices
into each 16 byte chunk that the
vector instructions work on.
Well, no, that's not what we do.
Make the portion smaller.
So once ohh I see once we
get the whole point. Yeah,
one point we use exit the vectorized loop,
do the next part of the algorithm and
then store the actual minimum value.
And the actual minimum value and index.
In just stored normally,
just like with,
just like with the old style
minmax minimum maximum but OK.
So this is essentially and then reset
when we enter again or redo the
tail which is just the normal loop.
OK, I'm trying to make sure
the camera can see it,
so in the case that we've got
like vector of T and we've got.
She happens to be like 1 byte and we
got like a whole bunch say this thing
is for concrete purposes 10 gigabytes,
which is a totally reasonable size.
Since we can only consume up
to 256 elements per portion,
you're saying that we're gonna
run the vectorized loop only
on like the 1st 256 elements.
So use cool vector instructions,
find the minimum out of this region,
exit the vectorized loop and then
we run the vectorized loop again on
the next 256 and then we find OK.
Is there a better candidate here
and so at each point we're finding
a current best known candidate.
And for minmax,
it could be a different locations
and we're still getting the advantage
of the vectorized loop because we
get to consume 256 bytes of time.
Yeah or more in the case of larger elements,
but we don't need to do anything
super fancy to like cleverly
split the index or something.
We're just saying OK,
because we can only store up to like 2
to the eight or two to 16 or whatever.
That's how many we can consume for vector.
For that does mean the end is actually
part of the asymptotic complexity though.
That the N so so let me explain
what happened.
With the it's just like that's a
bad one with the once we're done so.
So once we're at this part,
we need to find the the minimum
of these elements. Right?
And we could do that with a simple loop,
but we actually do it with a
bunch of simple instructions.
So we we go. Umm? Like so.
Umm?
So we go like this, right?
So OK, like conditional, not conditional.
So first we shuffle this vector.
Here, right?
Actually the order doesn't matter and.
For some of the sizes, it's.
And for some of the levels it's
increasing some decreasing,
but it doesn't OK.
I, I think this is the order for,
but anyway so we get 3/4. 1/2
OK and then we do and then we do the
minimum and so we get. Minimum. 43
minimum 3. UH-4
21.
Oh, I see by shuffling it and
then comparing the minimum,
you can compare the elements
against themselves. Yeah, OK,
and then we're just they're they're
counterparts essentially, yeah.
And then we do it again.
We shuffle this. Again.
Wait?
Yeah, OK, if you shuffle that
again then you can compare whatever
the minimum of four and three
was against two and one was,
and then the output will be.
Whoops, yeah, you may just come.
The output will be all identical and
they'll be the minimum of exactly values,
and they'll be one on one one in this case,
and then you just extract
whatever element it's because,
Yep, OK, that's exactly right.
That's interesting, so that's what this is.
So this is let's go to the one for
four because it's kind of easiest.
That's a win if we're doing like
what up to 16 bytes at a time.
We only need like 4 swap or 4
shuffles or something and minimums
rather than it's always a win.
Ohh cause no branches, it's branchless,
no branches, no data dependencies.
OK that's fancy OK so there may be
some situations where it's not a
win and I think the other thing.
So actually that that's the.
Yeah, so this is for 32 bit, so we do.
Yeah, so ohh yeah. So we swapped
the first two and then the 2nd 2.
Each min shuffle hmin yeah.
When we shuffle against itself.
OK, this is very enlightening.
Otherwise I would have looked
at their shuffles like what?
What are we doing here?
So that's what's.
And then, so here we're doing. Uhm?
2301 Yeah, so it's just swapping, OK?
Like it's just swapping sort of a halves
of yeah OK, because they're in order.
Yeah, this is and that also explains
why the shuffles get smaller as you
go down and and also to to point
out this isn't an order right?
Because so here we're starting
with swapping the 32 bit values,
but if you look up. At. What we do?
Should we go back to sharing? Yeah,
we should go back to sharing the screen.
Can I reclaim your chair? Yeah,
so but it just switched the camera over here.
No, give me one second.
So yeah, so if we look at for the first one,
then we do the same thing As for 32 bit.
And then we do the words
and then we do the bites.
So we're kind of doing
things in a different order,
but the order doesn't actually matter,
because because the shuffles are order
independence, they're essentially,
is that right? Alright, no well,
as long as you hit each element right min.
Kind of. Doing man of men of something right?
You just add the something to the big.
You know the big man?
OK yeah, let's switch.
OK, I I now feel prepared to follow
along with the rest of your code.
If you the camera.
Yeah, let's see, so there's some.
Yeah, so and then for this uh,
let's see. So I looked at it and.
So the sets. So these I think have.
Intels intrinsics. Intrinsic.
Talks aren't that good, but.
Which one is it using?
Umm?
This is said that the
eight right? Yeah, right.
So there's.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Intel has like, uh,
three point latency statistics
on that page, but they're like.
Little dubious. Umm?
And obviously like you can
have an instruction that, uh.
It's like has more latency than
you'd expect because the the
the resources are just utilized.
Yeah, so I think in some of these there's
like one or two cycles at the end.
That we could stick something in and
that are. And where the next instruction?
Is dependent. On on this funct.
Ohh yeah funk is so that it
can do minimum and maximum.
And. You know how is this?
Was that templated on ideas.
OK, so we're using a.
A function object as a template parameter.
OK, yeah, it returns right. So H funct.
Is this? And then the actual things.
It's not a functional object.
It's a Lambda. OK, I guess is a function.
A Lambda is a function object
that the compiler makes.
Yeah, OK, that's that's that's nice.
I mean it's.
Reducing the amount of code
we have to read by three,
so that's very much appreciated.
Yes, if only we could do
the rest with all the 816.
There's also some differences for eight,
OK for 64 bit. Uh,
the appropriate instruction is a the X512.
Thanks Intel.
Where is it?
Yeah. Yeah, so men, so here this is 32 bit.
We're using M min API 32 which is.
So you see Mm-hmm so DPM Inc.
Is AVX 512 and we're doing so?
Yeah, so MNE PI32 as wow.
That's been a lot of like anyway.
On instruction latency, but then
for 64 bit we do. Some blends.
Yeah we do and then blend the.
What is a blend? Is that combine 2
vector registers with the one? Yeah.
Uh, using a mask, which
one is it? It's API, yeah.
UM?
Yeah, so it it it has a mask of.
M128 mask. And the top bit.
Of the most significant bit of each.
Byte in that mask vector determines
which which source vector.
The value will will come,
will be taken from OK, so it doesn't
combine the integers themselves,
but you do get an arbitrarily pick,
which might you're taking from each
vector register based on the mask.
OK, right? Yeah,
and the reason the mask is a whole vector,
like for for the comparison instruction.
The result is a vector where.
No, the the passing comparisons
are set to all one.
Passing comparisons, yeah,
so like if it's a greater, less than.
Yeah, it's less than the ones.
Yeah, OK, I see the the result
is like 11111 and then just
means OK this whole byte was less
than this whole other byte, OK?
So because I I'm imagining uses
these vector instructions often,
find it useful to have ones in all positions.
So rather than requiring more vector
instructions to spit out additional ones,
or like sort of widen those ones.
Yeah, and there are, there are instructions
to especially narrow the ones.
OK, so you go from a massive
vector to a mask integer.
Or a mask scalar that's a bit field.
Uhm, yeah, that's very useful to that.
Alright? So this is dealing with the wrapper.
Ohh, the reason we have have
portion Max is for for for 8. Uhm?
OK, so has portion Max is essentially
the the case where we can't just
consume the whole input all in one
class because we could run these.
Yeah and we can always consume
the whole input, right?
That's because the elements are so
large that we have so few elements
that we can always fit in size 2.
So for for my own enlightenment,
can you look at the traits for four?
Did we get an X?
Do we get an architecture bitness
dependency on portion mask masks?
That's two, yeah we do indeed.
OK great.
So this this corresponds to
what I would expect.
OK, OK,
and then the portion is 1 bigger
than or exactly 2 to the 32 OK?
That that that aligns with my understand.
Ohh yeah,
that's a bit.
Yeah, they could have been written as one
left shift or one UL left shift 30 yeah,
but I'm part of that too.
Yeah someone's nice, nicer net
that we have digit separators we
ever live without. Yeah so. Yeah.
Let's see.
Max portion size is.
Right, because we do four in one go.
And I think the the indices are indices
into the vertical. OK, so. It's.
It's indices into these into these vectors.
OK, realize I'm pointing at
something that nobody can see,
but pointing out that the matrix of.
That sort of stacked input vectors.
OK, yeah, why is it?
Why is it multiplied by 16?
Or is that 16 coming?
Let's see this, oh,
this is the general minmax element,
so we don't have any.
We don't have any size dependency yet,
but it's saying that since
we're working with 16 byte.
Chunks that portion Max is the
number of portions we can consume.
So times 16 is the number of bytes.
Is that right, yeah. OK, OK,
and a portion size is indeed a byte line.
Yes, OK. Ohh yeah so. Yeah.
OK, I really like the name
byte length for the function.
I don't know if I like the name
portion size so much because the the.
The question is like interpretation.
There's a very strong assumption
in the STL that when we see size,
we're counting elements.
And if anybody's talking about bytes,
they really need to say bytes up front.
So that's why I love seeing Bike lane.
But portion size is like portion bite,
size, more self explanatory.
Better to err on the side of
being a little bit too verbose
and constantly saying right,
because the danger of not.
Saying so,
I don't know where else needs to be renamed.
Well. Umm?
And because Max portion size.
Or put Gates portion maxes
elements exactly exactly.
Yeah, portion Max is elements
and then Max portion size is
talking about fights then that is.
That is very very easy.
It is essentially what we're
trying to make up for with naming.
Here it is the lack of unit system.
We're converting between units
of elements and units of bytes,
and we don't want our spacecraft to crash
because we screw up the units. Yes.
OK, this is making more sense
now that I'm understanding the
terminology and so then yeah,
and then we just truncate it off so
that we do the right number of things.
OK, then we advance. Ohm knowing if I stuff.
We load the first chunk.
Load U, that's, uh unaligned load. Uhm?
Yeah. And we do the sign correction.
Uhm? We initialize the
minimum values to the current.
The minimum maximum values
to that first chunk.
Because they're, by definition,
the best known so far.
Yes, and then we initialize the
current indexes current indices to 0
because that's the current indices.
OK, it's in. It's a chunk index basically,
so they're all at the same yes,
or alternatively,
a vertical index vertical OK.
Yeah, so I see cause I see vertical
comes from thinking of it as
a matrix when I think so yeah,
instead of writing the whole vector out on
a single line like I do when I'm writing,
you know linear vector.
You're just sort of wrap around
and now you write one line per.
16 by chunk basically, and then,
the vertical index is OK.
What row are we on?
OK, that that makes sense that I
was confused why at first you're
writing it as a matrix and but now
it makes a lot more sense, yes?
Oh yeah, and then we enter an infinite loop.
It's not actually infinite loop.
Let's see. So let's see what do we do?
Stop at yeah, so that's the end.
And then we advance the first by one vector.
And we increment our indices.
So increase all of them at once.
So this first condition is if
we're done, so let's skip that.
UM? Let's see.
Timeline times like this
that I really appreciate.
Like VS codes code code folding
the yeah they all they added
colors nice yeah so yeah the
bracket colorization is awesome.
Yeah well so then we load our next.
Our next set of of of things and up at
the top. We initialized. Yes, yeah,
we initialize the minimum values to that.
Might be able to squeeze
some exercycles out there,
not repeat the work, but. Umm?
I don't really have a problem with.
Yeah alright.
Yeah, so then we.
If we're in a minimum mode. UM?
This is not equals to zero is
apparently a compiler bug.
When it raises a warning,
if you do that flag style thing,
and if context per interesting,
what warning does it emit?
Uh, see 40 it's. Like
comparison is not a bull or something.
It's some W4 warning that
we don't suppress interest.
Because elsewhere we've directly tested.
I mean, it's not.
I'm not actually.
This one is superfluous.
That's horrific.
That's it.
Else find the estl we've been
able to directly test the
results of wise and on them.
Directly, I've never been
super comfortable with it,
but for you know it seems reasonable.
All right so.
If this is a foreign Max only mode.
Uh, than we do, yeah OK so.
Is last we do a greater than? UM?
Between minimum and and current value.
Uhm, and for Max we flip it.
UM, and then we do, UM.
Ohh this is yeah OK.
Why, why we're doing naughties less?
Why is UM greater than being used here?
It's just stylistic.
Yeah, that's I think, let's see.
Uh, there's E here and there's GT,
But there's not Lt yeah.
Let's see if there is.
Yeah, you one could use Lt. UM?
Yeah, I find that surprising only because
the STL has a historical convention
of really preferring less than.
So so to see a greater than being used.
I don't mind that here because it's
the like vector code and. The sort of.
Delegate to less that you only have to
implement less doesn't really apply.
Ohh yeah, I mean I would be fine with seeing
breathlessly and greater than being used.
I find it surprising that.
One would be used and would
happen to be greater than right?
I think I see why because you don't need to.
Yeah, both the traits but the
yeah and also you don't like.
You're also not doing like you're
not saying not greater than,
you're just flipping the the
order of parameters around.
Later on, so yeah,
so you can get less from greater, yeah?
But I still find it very
confusing that greater would be
selected rather than less.
It's not necessarily ask for changes.
Yeah you, you're just selecting
a different one. I yeah I.
I don't mind it at all.
So once you do the comparison.
So is less is current values.
Is less than. Valves man. Umm?
And then you get a vector like
like I mentioned of all ones.
And then to get the index.
You know a blend V.
On the current minimum, indexes.
The current index which we just bumped
out all at once because if it is
then you want to select that index.
That's only gonna be constant ones. UM?
And and the and and the less than value.
And then.
You do the same thing for the values.
Umm?
See.
Ah.
Yeah, OK, so this is actually
a little bit interesting,
so notice you're getting the man
and you're passing in his less.
But if we look up at the trades. UM?
Uh.
For 32 bit.
We don't use it. We don't
use that mask, we just call
UMMNE PI32. And that's where.
But just directly takes the mural of each,
yeah. And that's because MNE PI64
is in a V X512, and you'll notice.
So this is so. This is 1 instruction,
and then or I throughput and latency of 1.
And the thing we do for.
Uh, here is blend V. Uhm?
Where we just select based
on the mask hmm and that is.
Is it API? Yeah it is API.
And that's two in a lower throughput.
Skylake, so it's a little bit slower. Now.
UM?
Yeah, and it. It also has a better
dependent, uh, better dependency chain.
So that's why we have to pass that in.
Intel said I really wish Intel
would ship the APX 512 stuff.
On processors, adult support
the actual 512 bit vectors. UM?
Yeah, so we select them and we update
that and then we go to the next
iteration of the loop etcetera etcetera.
So we do that. And now it's
time to do the horizontal part.
Be it to stop at. Where we finish.
The loop that we accident and do the tail.
Uh, But that's taken into account.
Let's stop that. So we we we get
to to stop at and this is the.
Consolidate the shuffling thing.
So if we're in.
Minimum mode we do admin.
And then we get.
One of the values is
there all the same. UM?
Or actually get any.
Did I complain about this?
Ohh yeah CVTS I that's fine.
OK, yeah I was complaining about
get the pause. But I was wrong.
Now let's see. UM?
Yeah, so this does the convert thing
which basically just truncates.
To wine. Whatever. OK,
it takes it takes a vector of values.
We assume that they're all
identical and we're just like
we just want to scale out of it.
I don't care which one. Yeah, OK.
I think it's always the first one, OK? Umm?
Uh, let's see.
And this is doing the classic.
Excuse me, this is doing the
classic comparison loop comparison.
Update them in and then.
This is tying together. The indices so.
Ohh let's see so this is.
Yeah, so this is the previous best
horizontal man and this is the so
we get the equal values. Move mask.
Takes the vector mask where where
elements are set to all ones and
if the high bid is set an element.
It'll set the bit in the
resulting integer to one.
So you get a 32 bit integer from that, OK?
Umm? And I mean really unsigned it,
but like. That's that's E.
You said that this just
sets everything to to one.
And then we take.
This is the case if if if yeah,
if there are. If there are equal.
If any of the values are equal.
Then we can pull out.
Let's see.
Yeah, then we. Pull out.
The current index. Otherwise.
Take the maximum index.
Ohh
ohh yeah so then?
That's why we pulled out the ones.
So then if. We had equal values.
We need to make sure that if
they are in different columns,
we still get the correct one.
So we then take the minimum of the indices.
OK no cause we wanna find the
first one for a minute element.
Yeah, yeah. And then.
Uhm? Let's see.
And then we pull out.
Let's see, you can't be equals.
Uh huh.
Yeah, this is definitely
definitely doing a lot.
I don't immediately see what it's doing.
I might get the general idea, I I I,
I figured out what it was doing
on Monday and I've now forgotten,
but that's how I was with,
uh, with Kerry yeah,
it's tying together the indices and the.
The values and then it
does a bit scan forward.
And then it takes the result of the
BIT scan forward and and extracts
that element from the vector values.
Yeah, for for me this indicates
the sort of test coverage that I'm
gonna wanna see and I see that
there are tests being added here
that need a lot of attention to
not only different element sizes,
but also the duplicate element case
that we're looking at both the
values and the indices coming out.
Yeah, especially when there are
duplicates across different tests are are.
He generates a bunch of tests
and then compares against.
The old algorithm OK, which is which is.
Yeah, so then we take the base and then.
Vertical Pass, which is the stride.
Plus the horizontal position OK.
Because we need to know which
chunk were we in and then OK,
we're looking at like the third
element within that chunk, OK?
And then if we're doing Max,
we do essentially the same thing.
Let's see. And then this is just.
Uhm? To do the different comparisons.
Yeah, initially this was a
ternary inside the if conditional,
which I complained about.
Yeah, that would be confusing.
Let's see. Yeah, OK.
And then here we've got the difference
between Maxwell element and Min Max element.
So this is something I wanted to see,
so I'm glad that it's here here.
Max Element finds the first maximum
min Max element finds the last Max.
Yep. That's why it's H Max.
Instead of men.
And then the same.
Thing there. Let's see.
So if we have the portion Max.
Uh. This kind of repeats some
of the stuff done at top.
I think Alex was asking if I,
I think the best way to if we
wanna eliminate this repetition
would be quite use. Go to.
Oh yeah, I'll label break
which I actually don't mind.
But yeah, I'm I'm.
I'm not a big caterer of go to.
Yeah I I am so I'm OK with some
repetition here alright and if
necessary like we could think about it.
I you know I yeah.
I mean it would be a go to that's
like a go to use this like a
labeled statement which I think is.
No, not not. Not the previous opinion,
but in any case.
UM?
Yeah, so we're gonna see
if we are at the end.
And it equals 0 means that this mask.
I mean, either we're at the very end,
or this masking masked out
all of the bits in the size.
In which case where the last
inside that last vector element.
And then we just do that computation again.
And advanced stop at. Uh.
Set base and we've already
advanced first, I think. Umm?
Load current values.
And then if we're in minimum mode.
The update. Men and IX men,
and if we're in maximum mode,
the update Max and I like that branch
could be done at the top too, but.
Uh, there's no reason to do it.
And there's no way. You know?
Like these branches are
OK because they're all,
so they're gonna get predicted
they're in the loop in their
constant over the holder.
So yeah, and these these material,
we've constexpr arts so,
oh that's true too either way.
There's actually some argument to
be had for changing some of this
stuff from if constexpr to to if.
Because in I think there are certain cases,
especially in admin. So for example.
If each min could be dynamic on the size.
Right? And. The UM?
If the branch is speculated. Then like you.
UM? You have a couple of cycles.
The the instruction right after it,
right after each func is called,
has a dependency on this
final min instruction.
Umm? And. I think min has.
No, no, it's only one second
latency. Umm? Yeah I did.
That there's some cases we're doing.
The If is better because.
There's no reason not to, basically.
Yeah, but also the the numbers on
the Intel and intrinsics guide are
not sufficient to determine that.
Because they're incredibly dubious anyhow.
Uh, let's see. Yeah yeah,
we advance if we're at the
if we're actually at the end.
Now we're at the end of the selves.
Uh.
Ohh yeah, so if we don't have like what?
Ohh yeah, so this is this is a 64 bit case.
You just break immediately.
And once we update things, we continue.
Which I kind of thought was confusing
in terms of the ordering of the loop.
It seemed like it was this.
The thing that essentially reruns the
vector algorithm for each syllable portion.
Yeah, this does the updating part of that,
but then it continues up to the top.
Starts it again.
Eat another advances.
Yeah, advances first,
after it does all that stuff OK,
but I think that's because it
has to initialize the values first.
Right, so because the first?
Well it's because the first iteration of
this trunking algorithm is is unique, right?
Because you thought you need
this load everything and say hey
we found the best stuff and if
you do the comparisons that it's
wrong because you just compare
it against zero or whatever.
Yeah?
So yeah. Ohm.
Yeah, and then we're done.
And then at the end.
We just do the tail, which is the normal.
And then we do this.
I checked that all the numbers match up.
It's good. Yeah, because at the end
you don't want that copy paste or
you saying or when you meant eight.
Yeah, so for the test we had last.
Last good known me in element.
So this is the normal.
Naive, Lou. UM?
And this is a the normal min Max loop.
We verify that that's the same
as what we do in minmax. Uhm?
Yeah, and so he tests.
He generates various sizes of. UM?
Of vectors. OK, so they're saying only one
per, so I I think we need to make sure.
Yeah, we need to make sure that
we get the actual special cases.
Yeah, it's it's random, which is good.
But the the extreme complexity
of this code, I think, demands.
A little more focused testing.
In addition to what's here.
The way that I was less concerned
about with like finding count.
Yeah, because especially because
finding count didn't really introduce.
He sort of, you know,
shrunken portion and entities whenever,
whenever we've got these
magic numbers like you know,
16 in the code that creates that.
We've been bit by this before the.
And what was it?
We ran into a bug where it was a sort.
I want to say it was a ranges.
Either range of sort or
stable sword or partial sort.
I think it might have been stable sort.
We only tested it for like
1617 something elements.
There's a hard coded constant in
there that when we get over 32 we do
special fancy stuff and the code didn't
work for large numbers of elements.
So whenever we see a constant the
code we need to test on the side.
Very, very well called coverage.
How does playing code coverage work?
If you compiled the code,
the actual CPP file with MSVC.
I have no idea.
I've never run client code coverage.
In theory that would be an interesting
metric to capture in practice
because we're so heavily templated,
we've never really explored code coverage.
Not saying that it wouldn't be bad,
or would it be good,
but we are so far from having that as a
heuristic for a metric that we could look at.
I I would I can sort of.
I mean, yeah we could.
We could bench coverage,
but I think I think that the asking a lot.
Yeah, I think so too.
Here I think.
Yeah, these are, yeah completely
equal vectors vectors of equal chunks.
I'm thinking focusing testing on
the duplicate cases would be very
interesting cases where we know
we're gonna have duplicates in
the same positions or the same.
Modulo and you consider this.
The code is reasonably
like it's been fact about,
that all the trade stuff is centralized,
so I am not as concerned that we're
gonna find something that only fails
for like 2 bytes and not for 8 bytes.
There's a little bit of that
because the portion size,
but having at least some coverage that
OK if we've got a duplicate element
here and here and they're both the
minimum we need to find the first one.
We're running minmax element,
we need to find the last one for the maximum.
Yeah, just having one case that would
really make you feel better about.
Yeah yeah, this is this.
Definitely good.
It's a good start. Yeah.
And so the other reason why I think
that we need a little bit more
interesting is that we're using.
The random number generator,
just as a quick way to spin out. Sort of,
you know reasonable looking coverage,
but it's specifically not a randomized
test case that's generating new
numbers every time we run it.
This is deterministic,
preceding it always with 1729 or
whatever he chose the seed to be.
So every time we run this program,
it's always going to generate.
Only generates 124 OK. Yeah,
so we do get multiple portions for 8 bits.
OK 8 byte, 8 wait.
Actually do we because they're
in the trunk so you might not.
Yeah, because they're their
indices into the column,
so you would need 255.
Times 16. OK, that's pretty.
Yeah like four 4000.
Yeah, I actually don't think.
Let's see, and then for two.
65,000 that's alone.
Now we do need to worry about.
OK, how long does this take to run?
So like for the for the cases
like either 2 by where we've got,
you know 65K or something,
maybe a little bit too much to like.
Test automated having like a little bit
of manual testing would be reasonable,
and of course 232 is trying to extreme.
But certainly for like the the one by case,
I think we could test the
yeah rerun the portion there.
Because that's definitely it.
Yeah, it's it's.
It's the worst in the sense
that it's control flow.
Which state and control flow
are things to worry about?
Yeah.
I mean, if necessary,
we could explore extending this
test to be truly randomized to the
strategy that we've used elsewhere,
which is like the sort of the the
second highest level of stringency is.
We get the test to generate
random values at runtime,
and we have to log the seed,
and then we say OK, if this test fails,
do not ignore and rerun it.
You must report this to the
maintainers and give us this seed,
and then we can replicate that failing
run up, and we do that for CARICOM.
We do that for a couple other tests
where there may be such obscure
failures that the cumulative coverage
of running it over and over in the
harness could grant stuff here.
I don't necessarily know that we need that,
but that is something that we can have.
The ultimate is pure exhaustive,
just like every possible value for
min and Max element, it's not.
It's a lot harder to do because you got
to worry about duplicates and non duplicates,
so you can't just like test all
combinations is there in one.
I don't think exhausted
is the reason we're here,
but certainly having some focus
test cases of this is the same.
All the portions or whatever.
Complexity,
yeah,
we're we're definitely gonna fudge
the complexity requirement.
The fun thing is that if we know
that it's less,
then they can't observe how many
times we're revoking their predicate.
And are they going to complain if
we come back to them unless wall
clock time that they expected because
we ran a vectorized algorithm?
As long as we're not like messing
with the asymptotic complexity,
which would be very bad, we are though,
are we changing end to end login in
terms of and the number of elements?
Yes,
the case where when when does that happen?
Because if you have multiple portions
you do the horizontal part multiple times.
But the horizontal part is constant
time for number of chunk, right?
Or for the size of the ports?
Like the size of the portion is
determined by the element size, right?
Yeah, but it does end log N comparisons.
OK, so I'm working well it does,
you know four log 4 comparison?
Yeah, but that's constant in terms
of the number of elements, right?
Sorry elements size.
Yeah, but you it's times. Ohh.
So what I'm saying is imagine
you've got a one byte element.
We know that the portion size is 256
elements so we will run the algorithm
N number of elements in the whole thing
divided by 256 times that many times.
We're going to run the vector
algorithm that's on over 256.
Then you're saying we're
going to do this extra.
That is, that is going to be
fixed in terms of the number 256,
so it's constant, but.
It adds.
Like
it?
It still adds like an act like a.
A number of comparisons that depends on.
Yeah, yeah. It's essentially saying instead
of running like exactly in comparisons,
we're around like you know
1.2 or 1.01 or something.
And yeah, but it's still linear.
It's a constant factor. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
and since it's not really observable,
I think we can get away with
it like I view this.
Yeah, it's definitely I.
If you complain about this, like.
Yeah yeah you want.
Do you want us to make your code faster
enough like I think what we're doing
here is strictly less weird and standard
bending than our debug comparisons
where we do take things like hey,
you know you're only allowed in comparisons
of the issues to find predicate,
we can only find do it twice only.
Find the complexity when
we make the code slower.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
very few people complain when we get past.
Let's see what is the types,
I don't know if camera is camera.
I'm trying to find the
on the compiler warning.
Yeah, one mode was a clean.
You know, I'm not an enum class.
Yes, oh, I think it was in there.
Yeah, it's a normal, you know.
So in I guess.
Yeah, the underlying type.
The default to be interior and
then mode itself is another,
so it's you know equals enum or enum
and enum and enum and the actual
variable was a template parameter right?
I mean non type template parameter.
Yes, I suspect that's significant
as well as a constant.
Was the warning something like conditional
expression was constant or something?
It it's an if constexpr prayer.
Yeah, the computers had a little
trouble with or the best acting
classes had a little trouble.
Maybe fix it that that was just
in with certainly wouldn't be the
first time if Constexpr complained
about a constant expression.
So essentially it would be for a while.
Tyler warning and with the
self contained repro,
we should just report it's part of
you know that the east wall is one is
egregious and probably not necessary.
Yeah,
that would definitely need to be fixed.
At the end I would like to at
least understand what we're trying
to permanent work around there
before permanent work around.
And playing Jack, it is yeah 5:30
so we should worry about dinosaurs.
Yeah, this is very enlightening.
I did not understand this
PR when I first glanced.
Any like an entire day at least?
Maybe like 2 days to.
Well, an entire day of work like
spread over a couple days to actually.
Decipher what the hell is going on.
But I mean the actual algorithm is
not that horrible. It's kind of.
It's just having to handle
all of 145 sign in and sign.
It's kind of well, I'm going to call min.
I'm going to call vectorized min in
chunks and then what do I do next?
And it kind of leads you to this conclusion,
yeah, but the speedups from the vectorized
algorithms are so amazing that it is
well worth especially for this this,
this really cool.
Yeah, this is because you're
breaking the the inner loop.
And anything if you do the
naive wouldn't even know that.
I don't know if we were doing that before,
but. If you do the naive loop,
each iteration of the loop is
dependent on the last iteration.
Yeah, like nothing better.
Do you like one comparison?
You like one you like 2 comparisons, right?
One for the actual comparison,
and then one for the loop,
and then you just sit there
on the next comparison.
Wait, yeah,
waiting for the result to be available.
And I actually think implementing this
exact algorithm in scale our code.
Might improve performance,
but now that we haven't or might
improve performance even when we
can't use the vectorized version,
yeah unfortunately.
Then we start running into the
if somebody's noticing how times
are revoking their predicate.
Then we do start losing.
Yeah,
well when actually no because
we don't have to do any login.
Because the same number, no.
So what we're duplicating comparisons here.
I see if you just rearrange the
order in which we do the comparison.
More of them when we do it.
If when we do the comparison,
the size of the type increases.
Right, so if we.
Like if we do.
This. I let's see.
Yeah, so we do this comparison and we get
this and then when we do the next one.
We we only compare.
Like we just only do this.
Right and the minimum of three and four and
the minimum of four and three are the same.
Hmm, we know that, and so we just.
We mask those bits out and put it that way.
Yeah, we would be avoiding the very
long dependency chain by doing them in
a different order and sort of keeping
more results suspended in the error.
Yeah, more complexity on that.
We need to worry about wait,
what if we end early?
We don't have multiple 4 or whatever
elements but could be feasible.
Yeah, if that would keep the same,
so that's an idea.
Even for user defined types of course.
They also you know if it's a user
defined type and it has a less
operator and the less operator doing
a bunch of stuff then it might be
that you know it's kind of enough.
Yeah, yeah,
at that point we have questions
like is it diminishing returns.
Is this really worth spending a
lot of information complexity?
Whereas Ohh,
you're running min element unlike integers,
you know integers are super common.
So yeah,
I mean this is like an order
of magnitude speedup.
Yeah, we will do almost anything
for an order of magnitude.
The common types.
So yeah, that's an idea.
And then there's,
you know.
Twiddling around with like?
D vector or D templating.
This a little bit and rolling
some of the stuff that's done at
compile time here into runtime.
That'll make stuff slower.
Either it either won't matter,
it will make stuff slower and absolute
characters on a micro benchmark.
If you're only testing one element size.
But if you do,
if you call these with multiple sizes.
In a row it it could help performance.
Yeah that might not be a pure win.
So yeah, I believe that it's a lot of work.
And it also might be very CPU specific.
I'm sorry, yeah.
This changes,
I already requested changes so.
Yeah, that's kind of the.
Because a lot of that is like tucking.
Like tucking branches and
comparisons and stuff in.
After specific vector and basically
saying oh, the processor is gonna
be busy doing this other thing,
so I may as well keep
all the execution units.
Yeah, I may as well do this.
I may as well do this extra work.
Yeah it's like in exchange for
not for you know not not not
duplicating the code with templates.
I might just do this extra work
when I might as well and then.
If I use it with,
if I use different sizes,
everything's already there.
But it's yeah. I mean,
this is not a lot of code.
So yeah, I I don't know how big
these instructions are, but.
I think it's a lot.
It's a lot for maintainers to understand,
so I'm happy with this as
an initial improvement.
Get that order of magnitude and
then later on we can think about
potentially tuning it more.
Worried about like the correctness issues?
Ohh great looks like.
Already been fixed.
When was this fixed? April 8th.
Wow yeah, so yeah, this would not
yet have shipped in a public preview,
so Alex would not have seen it.
Didn't we just, ohh yeah, it's.
But we're the VS release is so we're
going to be shipping on a fast frequency,
but the latency is significant.
So stuff that was like checked in and
should we just give it a transition?
VSO, yes, that would be reasonable to site,
but I would cite the where the PR number.
Yeah the PR number.
Because that way we can look at
it so MSVC PR blog because that
way we can go to directly say,
OK, Jonathan fixed this in April.
It's available.
Actually,
we should know when this is gonna ship.
This is gonna be 17 to preview
two sorry yes 17.
Two preview two.
Yeah but no seven sorry 17 three preview
22 just 17 too many seventeens 17.
Two just went general viability
17 three Preview 2 is the next
one that's going to contain
all sorts of awesome fixes.
But we have to specify date in the future.
Yeah,
we have to be one behind though because.
Premium mobile like we can't
just make the change now no.
No we can't but but the the transition
comment could be ohh transition
comma 17 three Preview 2 why do
you do this and that will be the
reminder that when somebody goes
and updates the tool set if it's 17
three Preview 2 to go get rid of the
work around let's see where is the thing.
I think you could look for mode
and I think you might have just.
Pass one of them.
Yeah here.
OK.
Auto linker doesn't do the installation.
Yeah that yeah. Also, it's a common.
Yes, I do love searching for that. Uh.
What can I put to separate, recommend,
cut out the MSVC bit, make the
comment just say 17 three Preview 2.
That's all we need in the source code.
Then if you yeah, close the code
block and then your comment here.
Psych, MSD CPR law and that will be.
So that's good. Yeah,
this is part of our long term strategy
of preventing us from drowning in an
endless sea of compiler workarounds.
Like we always get some,
but we gotta get rid of them at some
point and consistently commenting them
is the way to avoid having tutors
that end up being like a decade old.
Or just weird bits of code that nobody
can remember. What we were doing.
Yeah Ohh Karen asked what the rationale
is and I think we've covered it.
Which is that it makes.
The Min, Max and Min Max algorithms
like 10 or 20 times faster, yeah?
It's a huge speed up.
And yeah, and the rationale
behind why that is, it's like.
Vector instruction is good and.
Huge dependency,
you know interloop dependencies.
Not good, yeah,
and the ability to make code automatically
fast when somebody upgrades is
like just the the best thing ever.
And not only is it an interloop dependency,
but it's also kind of unpredictable,
yeah?
Yeah, if you have random data
that that comparison is gonna be.
It's gonna be taken in half the time,
yeah yeah yeah excellent.
Excellent point really so so you
you you really can't win there.
Yeah, so this is a substantial speedup,
and the proposed future directions are
in a VX2 version and an AVX 512 version.
We have to benchmark it,
because obviously moving up to
bigger vectors uses more memory.
Yeah, and also. And so with the previous
8X512 PR that we were unable to find
actual speedups from that, so I if P.
X2 has legit actually speed up, yeah, 3X2.
We've seen quite good results 3X512.
We would definitely need to make
sure that it's going to be faster
before committing any code there.
Yeah, plus, it's available is
still quite limited, but for AVX,
2 AVX 512 it would be nice if
there's a couple AVX 512 instructions
that would be great to use, but.
Yeah.
So yeah, that's not PR.
It's a neat PR.
Hopefully we can get it merged.
Relatively soon, yeah,
I'll take a look at it soon.
Hopefully we can get it soon for 17.
Three preview three.
Yeah, which is the next thing
that our code is flowing into.
Yeah, and then we'll eventually
have to port it to neon.
Yes, there's a separate PR
for extending all this to R64.
Well, it only does reverse.
Which is what we had vectorized
before Alex cause teeth ended
stuff yeah but yeah yeah we're
gonna need to you know have
additional follow up PR's too.
Yeah but.
Yeah, I mean now that we have
the structure of this code,
doing it in neon is good.
We do need to discuss.
Our general strategy for once,
we have vectorized
algorithms for multiple Isas.
But yeah. That's for another time.
So yeah, I think that about wraps it up.
Cool thanks everyone.
Yeah, any remaining questions.
It looks like that's it in the at least
put everybody to sleep. And yeah,
probably stop the recording now, yeah?